eric prince the former navy seal and
founder of blackwater the infamous
military contractor that took on lots
and lots of work during the iraq and
afghanistan wars was recently on the
sean ryan show and he talked about
bitcoin cryptocurrencies the u.s dollar
and geopolitics there's a fascinating
conversation because this is an
individual who has immense amounts of
data and information at its fingertips
and he's also highly connected with
various global leaders around the world
in the conversation prince points out
that he believes that sanctions are
actually weakening the us dollar on a
global stage the u.s dollar is the
global reserve currency but he points
out that those financial sanctions
against russia and other countries are
actually incentivizing various countries
that are large and may not be as
friendly with the united states to come
together and start to do trade in a
bilateral way without using the dollar
as that common unit of account now of
course eric prince sharing his own
personal opinions but it is fascinating
to hear him talk about what he calls
society level change with the united
states if they lose u.s dollar dominance
having to pay for many of their prior
errors here's exactly what eric had to
say about financial sanctions and the
potential diminishing power that the us
dollar may carry on that global stage so
for the last
70 years
we've enjoyed the dollar being the
world's reserve currency right and what
that allows
washington to do is spend trillions of
dollars extra part of the of the aura or
the the facade
of the the dollar being the world's
reserve currency is that there's this
american military hegemony right we have
this amazing military that can smack any
target anytime anywhere
and and when you have the debacle that
was afghanistan a failure in iraq a
failure of deterrence in ukraine when
that failure of deterrence now leads to
conflict between russia and ukraine and
now everybody goes
hog wild on sanctioning everything
russia right russia is still the largest
energy producer in the world they're
going to sell their stuff somewhere and
somebody's going to buy it right they
want to be paid in rubles yeah and
they'll trade with india
who can pay with rupees and the chinese
will pay with renminbi right so they
call it the three rs and so they create
a trading block to further reduce
the the hegemony that the dollar has in
trade
when when the dollar loses that status
then our idiots in washington's can't
spend an extra trillion dollars a year
and when america has to finally live
within its means and start to pay that
debt back
holy [ __ ] that is
that is society transforming level
change now when you hear eric prince
talk about these things the first
question i have well what exactly would
this future look like if the financial
sanctions actually do weaken the us
dollar and later in the conversation
with sean ryan prince lays out that
weimar germany which is decades-old
story could be a cautionary tale the
united states should pay attention to
here's prince describing why germany is
so important to understand as we move
forward in this current monetary policy
regime you took a country like germany
that lost world war one
and they printed and printed and printed
money
and the mighty
history of the german prussian society
collapsed
and all that wealth was destroyed
because it went from
you know one mark one german mark to buy
a loaf of bread
up to
a billion marks
to buy a loaf of bread just
hyperinflation that ran away
and the german society elected
a psychopath like adolf hitler
and that's the that's the kind of
insanity we have to prevent
now of course
eric prince myself and anyone else who's
watching this has no clue what's going
to happen in the future but to
understand the intricacies and the
complexities that revolve on the
geopolitical stage when you add in
central banks monetary policy and
various other issues it all becomes
clear that we could be headed towards
some pretty bumpy times now one of the
weird things in the bitcoin community is
that the more you understand the legacy
system the more you realize that we need
a new system there's lots of issues and
eventually those issues will come to a
head
now i don't like the doomsday stuff i
actually am a deep deep optimist i
believe that we live in the greatest
time in human history it's the most
prosperous and safest time
and i hope that we have a better future
than our past but i also understand that
you have to be rational you have to take
an honest look where are we headed and
what can we do to mitigate the risks
as we continue to see the geopolitical
stage unfold listening to someone like
eric prince even though he's
controversial even though many people
disagree with some of his actions or
previous things he said it's important
as i mentioned he's got immense amounts
of information at his fingertips and
he's very well connected on the global
stage with leaders people of power and
influence watching this interview was
eye-opening for me and to hear him talk
about financial sanctions weakening the
us dollar dominance and potentially
leading or contributing to
hyperinflation in the u.s
it's not something that's guaranteed
something that i hope never happens but
it's something that we should understand
we should pay attention to and we should
encourage our leaders to do everything
they possibly can to mitigate that risk